that's a bokken your reaction to the
news of so Jeremy Haywood staff
it's very sad very sad news and I'd like
to join the prime minister in her
tribute to Sir Jeremy both in terms of
his work and in terms of his life he
related epitomize at the best of public
service working at the top of the civil
service and making such a great
contribution he'll be sadly missed by so
many colleagues in the civil service and
of course our thoughts are with his
friends and family at this very very
difficult time and it's sad that we
don't have him still here as a person
but also sad we don't have him here to
work on important projects going forward
yeah those work important projects that
you talk of of course he it seems that
he worked as long as possible on bright
said a very big challenge for the civil
servant and the government as a whole
and there are reports this morning that
Theresa May is effectively preparing to
try and make the whole of the UK join in
a customs union with the European Union
after brexit temporarily perhaps but
still in order to try and avoid that
hard border in Northern Ireland surely
this is something that you must welcome
because it's pretty close to Labour's
policy isn't it well labour has led the
way in terms of our demands for a common
sense respecting of the referendum
results and delivering a brexit that
works and interests of jobs consumer
protections environmental protections
and businesses but there is a lot of
speculation has been a kind of running
commentary on what the prime minister
may or may not come back with I'd like
to see what she actually comes back with
I know things are being briefed
I think Downing Street has referred to
it as speculation at this stage but of
course one of Labour's policies is that
we should have a customs union with the
European Union in order to protect the
economic progress of our country nodes
protect jobs and businesses so if the
withdrawal agreement was for the UK to
stay in a customs union or an effective
kostas union with the EU would you vote
for it well
Kirstin and the Labour Party of set out
are six tests that we will apply to
whatever deal treasom a comes back with
but things are very very uncertain
because she's not only negotiating with
the European Union
she's actually negotiating with her
cabinet and with some extreme people on
her back benches and indeed in the
cabinet so I don't want to guess what
the Prime Minister's going to come back
with our tests Eclair if it doesn't meet
our tests then we will be voting against
any deal of course it's still possible
that Teresa may encouraged by some of
the right-wingers in her party might
actually come back with a No Deal
scenario but let's see what she actually
comes back with there's been a lot of
speculation and a lot of the false
stories throughout this whole
negotiation process actually okay so for
our viewers what are the six tests then
that Labour say the PM must meet well
the six tests are that we would want a
customs union with the European Union
that we want the equivalent benefits to
the single market that we want the
Northern Ireland Board issue to be
maintained in a way that also protects
the Good Friday Agreement than we want
no diminution in workers rights in
environmental protections in consumer
rights and it protects jobs removes and
needs for tariffs and protects the
economy in the best way possible if
those tests aren't met we being clear
we'll be voting against it but the
pressure now is on the Prime Minister to
come back with something that can bring
the country together and actually
deliver a brags that that respects the
referendum but also doesn't turn Britain
into a tax haven off the shores of
Europe we don't want deregulation in
environmental consumer or workers rights
or anything else we don't want it to be
used as a smokescreen
pretory a vision of a Victorian Britain
of the kind of that Jacob Riis Marg
Boris Johnson and others would like to
see I'm a little bit confused because
that sounds slightly different to the
test that I have a strong and
collaborative future relationship with
the EU the exact same benefits fair
management of migration defending rights
and protections
to national security and delivering for
regions and nations for the UK these are
these are all the key things that were
talking about obviously we've talked
about our immigration policy that after
we lead the European Union we have a new
immigration policy of fair and
reasonable managed immigration policy
dan Abbott talked to the day in her
speech about how we still want to be
working cross-border when it comes to
tackling crime and terrorism because you
know we need to maintain the benefits
for example of European arrest warrant
but we want those benefits and if those
benefits aren't capped then we'll be
voting against the deal and that's what
people need to know as it stands I can't
envisage a situation where Theresa May
is going to manage to negotiate with her
cabinet with her back benches and with
the European Union to deliver a deal
that protects those things and meets
those tests but let's see what happens
and I was hoping you might be able to
clear something up for me after the
budget as well and because of course
Philip Hammond announced cuts to income
tax raising at the personal allowance so
does labour I think that's a good idea
or a bad idea well we put down an
amendment which was consistent with our
general election manifesto at the last
general election which would increase
taxes for the top 5% of earners ice and
that amendment and labour voted for that
amendment so that people getting paid
over 80,000 pounds a year would pay more
tax we were clear in our manifesto that
those that get paid less than 8,000
pounds in other words 95% of people
shouldn't be paying increased tax under
a Labour government and that's why we
voted in the way we did that's why we
put for the amendment in last week why
didn't you oppose tax cuts that would
benefit those top earners that you were
just talking about
we didn't oppose tax cuts which actually
in the budget which she delivered so
little for people on middle and low
income would actually give people on
middle and lower incomes some extra
money in their pocket in the context of
a budget what she delivered so little
for them
we abstained on that but we made our
position very clear by putting down our
own amendment which consistent with
Labour's manifesto consistent with our
values for the many not the few said
that the tax is that we would increase
would be on the top 5% of earners those
who earn over 80,000 pounds a year and
that that was very clear we set that out
and would also obviously as you know be
cracking down on tax avoidance and tax
evasion by the super-rich which is being
carried out on an industrial scale okay
and just finally South Thornton who is
the chair of the national police chief's
council said on Wednesday that because
of budget squeezes the police need to
focus on core policing they don't have
time effectively to look at crimes such
as misogyny what's your view on that is
it is she right that's very very
troubling I mean the police have been
saying that since the Conservative
government cooked police numbers by
21,000 it's being harder and harder to
do their very valuable job violent crime
is up reoffending is up and the
statistics have come out the other day
which show that serious repeat offenses
of the most serious kind have gone up
and the amounts of people being despite
crime going up the amounts of people
being charged and convicted is going
down - it's very very concerning the
police should have the resources in
order to tackle crime at all levels and
actually things like misogyny and racism
when it's that in the form of verbal
abuse a part of a trajectory leads
towards actually violent crime as well
these things can't be separated she's
very concerning what the police say and
that's why labor would start off on
doing the damage the conservative cause
by recruiting 10,000 extra police
between extra police officer in every
community because actually whether it's
terrorism or antisocial behavior
community policing is very important in
terms of the intelligence gathering and
the community relations to tackle those
important issues